el pueblo de Colombia salió a las calles
de Bogotá
miles de personas se adueñaron de las
calles de la capital para marchar contra
las reformas Fiscales propuestas por el
presidente Gustavo Petro algunos civiles
apuntaron directamente contra la figura
del mandatario con carteles pidiendo su
salida
[Música]
que está llevando al sector de
hidrocarburos que es la base de la
macroeconomía en este país
algunos ciudadanos temen por una
desaceleración de la economía
del crecimiento económico es que si no
hay un crecimiento económico en un país
Pues todos nos vamos a ver perjudicados
en la parte económica hay que tener
conciencia de que él no solamente está
gobernando por su pacto histórico sino
para toda una nación colombiana el
proyecto del gobierno colombiano que
apunta a recaudar más de 20 billones de
pesos adicionales aún debe superar las
instancias de aprobación del senado y la
cámara baja la propuesta abarca una
sobretasa al sector de hidrocarburos que
va hasta el 15% para el petróleo y hasta
el 10% para el carbón
en tanto que entre otras cuestiones
también instala un impuesto del 0,5% de
los patrimonios de más de 3000 millones
y del 1% para los demás de 5000 millones
en tanto que se eliminarán los tres días
sin iva a la canasta familiar y habrá
impuesto a productos cotidianos como
bebidas azucaradas golosinas y embutidos
esto sucede en medio de una devaluación
del peso colombiano la de este sábado
fue la tercera manifestación en contra
de la Administración que asumió el
pasado 7 de agosto
[Música]